joining us on the line is Andrew Clavin
my good friend host of the Andrew Clavin
show over at Daily wire calm go check
them out you've heard of sub host for me
sometimes I know it's a bad day when you
sub house but sometimes he doesn't and
he's you know mediocre Andrew thanks for
joining the shop bureau what a great
introduction okay so before we jump into
news of the day I know that you had to
take on Martin Scorsese's Irishman which
is now winning all of the Critics Awards
you know I watched it it took me several
days because the movie like you actually
have to clear an enormous block of time
and I don't have that sort of time and I
don't feel like I lost anything by
watching it like 15 minutes at a time
because the thing never ended it was
like fog nari and rings cycle and
nothing happens for basically three
hours and then Robert DeNiro spoiler
alert dies yeah it's this terrible movie
it's just a bad movie and it's like it
you know the reason it's the reason it's
a bad movie is because it's not about
what it seems to be about the that
technique of where they make the actors
look younger they've got Al Pacino who's
80 or whatever and Robert De Niro who's
80 and Joe Pesci they're all so old and
they use computer techniques to make
them look they try to make them look
like they're 20 but they look like
they're about 40 plus it's just a 40
year old face on this hunched slow 80
year old body and they talk they solve
those gruff 80 year old voices and the
reason they did that is because those
are the guys who kind of brought a
Martin Scorsese along those are the guys
from Mean Streets the guys who were
stars of his big movies and the movie is
really about Martin Scorsese saying
goodbye to filmmaking and to a genre
that he loved that really doesn't
resonate that much anymore it was kind
of like a bad version of The Tempest
where Shakespeare has Prospero like bury
his wand and his magic book in the
ground saying goodbye to his arts you
know and this was this was really about
Scorsese saying goodbye to his filming
that's very self-indulgent it's not what
we go to the movies to see we don't go
to movies to see movies about movies you
know it's and so none of the characters
really made sense plus the history is
all ridiculous I mean that's me it's
about Jimmy Hoffa and that's not what
happened to Jimmy Hoffa even though some
of it is still a mystery we know better
than that so really it was just boring
yeah and I thought it was awful by the
way if you don't know if you've seen
Ford versus Ferrari yet that's a good
film I hear that's great I haven't seen
it yet I like knives out and you're in
it you're if there's a Ben Shapiro
analog in knives out yeah you're not the
first person to tell me this there are a
couple reviewers who said the same
so now I definitely will not watch that
movie I'm also very much looking forward
to not watching bombshell which is this
little Oscar bait flick I do love that
Hollywood is like we take me to so
seriously that we're making two separate
movies about Roger Ailes one for HBO and
one for general mass-circulation
and zero movies about Harvey wines and
and not only that George Stephanopoulos
who covered up the women for Clinton is
now at the ABC where they're covering up
the Jeffrey Epstein story okay so drew
I'd be remiss if I did not ask your
opinion on the brilliant performance by
our Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi
today she announced that indeed the
Democrats will impeach which is about as
shocking as Rosie O'Donnell coming out
of the closet way back when and it's
just that there was no shock involved
obviously from the moment they announced
impeachment inquiry it was moving in
this direction and then she got very
offended that anyone would suggest that
she's doing this because she hates Trump
because as a good Catholic she hates no
one except for unborn babies apparently
so what was your take on all this thing
it's so sad I mean she first of all I
feel that Pelosi was kind of pushed off
a building by the left I mean she knows
this is bad medicine she knows this is
no good that people don't care nobody
cares
Chuck two hottest hottest on MSNBC
saying they should force the the
candidates to stop campaigning so people
will watch these impeachment hearings
the impeachment hearings have been a
goat rodeo they've been embarrassing I
mean it really it really is it's just
terrible to have Nancy Pelosi go on and
parade her sorrow and her love of
America and her dedication to the
founding is just absurd yesterday at
these Judiciary Committee hearings they
had these three elite law professors
come on and say oh yes you know we have
to we have to impeach Donald Trump one
of them this guy Noah Feldman had
written a huge article for the New York
Times Magazine praising Sharia law I
mean this is who their experts are one
of them was so hated Trump so much he
had to cross the street when she was
near the hotel in Washington beautiful
hotel the Trump built I mean these are
like loons but the whole the whole thing
has been about these credentialed elites
coming forward and saying well we don't
really know anything but we don't like
the president that's been the entire
thing guys in uniform come forward in
the New York Times says oh look at their
gray hair isn't the chiseled features of
their veracity it's just amazing and
we're supposed to go like okay in
well you must be you guys must be
important credential people so we'll
give up our elected president yeah I
mean it's absurd on its face it's also
absurd I mean listen I have the
credentials and you have the no hair and
yet we are apparently not reassuring
enough for the American public and we're
well we're saying I think that's the
time well honestly the most enjoyable
story of the week obviously was Camilla
Harris dropping out of the presidential
race we're both from California and
watching her campaign just implode just
completely collapsed in on itself and
create a black hole it was just
unbelievably wonderful in every respect
what's your quick take on comma Harris
dropping well it's a long fall from the
top tier and I think she just fell she
just fell for the press the press looked
at her she's black she's a woman they
thought perfect that she'll be the
perfect president she was even you and I
were worried about her when she first
entered we were both worried about it
but she was a terrible candidate she was
unappealing she had that horrible
cackling laugh all she wants to do is
ban people plus she bragged about how
tough she was as a prosecutor which the
left hates they think all the criminals
should be left free because they're just
oppressed minorities ruined by evil
America so she really had nowhere to go
at any time and Tulsi Gabbard really
just kind of crushed her and said it was
definitely fun to watch all drew I'm
glad that you could stop by or at least
I'm you know sort of wishy-washy on this
thing so yeah so drew thanks so much for
something that Sandra Clavin you can
catch his show over at daily wear now
comments why should subscribe it daily
wire comm slash subscribe and join our
team drew thanks so much for time really
appreciated your great talkative